le fn premier parti attrape après ces
élections européennes de peu mais c'est
inscrit dans le marbre le front national
réalise 18 60% des voix
en 2009 le parti frontiste n'avait
obtenu que 4 60% des suffrages un
résultat d'autant plus regardées à la
loupe que c'est dans cette ville
socialiste que siègent notamment en
qualité de conseiller municipal
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
benoît hamon le parti de marine le pen
devance de quelques voix la liste
socialiste et la liste front de gauche
l'ump est le quatrième parti à noter
également que seulement 25% des
électeurs trappistes se sont déplacés
aux urnes
le fn qui arrive en seconde position à
la verrière avec à 17,16 % des voix
derrière la liste front de gauche
couleur politique du maire sortant le ps
est troisième l'ump 4e en 2009 le front
national n'avait réalisé que 3,49 % des
voix une surprise à magny les hameaux
villes socialistes l'ump arrive en tête
avec 16 points 64% des voix talonné par
le ps 16 34% par contre pas de surprise
à elancourt l'ump réalise 25,49 % des
voix le maire de la commune jean michel
fourgous était septième sur la liste
d'alain lamassoure mais le résultat du
parti dans la circonscription de l'île
de france ne lui permet pas d'être élu
seuls quatre députés ump iront à
strasbourg les autres communes de
l'agglomération concerne leur couleur
politique à guyancourt c'est le parti
socialiste qui arrive en tête avec 18
40% des voix devant l'ump le fn et la
liste udi modem à montigny le bretonneux
la ville du divers droite michèle losier
l'ump réalise 20 77% des suffrages
devant la liste udf modem
même cas de figure à voisins le
bretonneux la commune avait été emporté
en mars dernier par l'ue dit alexandra
rosetti le parti centriste réalise 21 02
% des suffrages devancé de deux points
par l'ump le front national réalise plus
de 12% des voix là où en 2009 il n'avait
même pas atteint les 2% voisins le
bretonneux qui remporte la palme du
civisme pour l'agglomération plus de 50%
des électeurs inscrits se sont déplacés
aux urnes au tour de saint quentin en
yvelines a noté que l'ump confirme son
ancrage
un mot pas la ville auparavant divers
gauche avait basculé à droite aux
municipales de mars
même cas de figure à bois d'arcy où
l'ump fait plus de 23 % des voix contre
12% pour le ps
dans ces deux villes auparavant à gauche
à noter la forte progression du front
national qui arrive en seconde position
un fn également sur la deuxième marche
aux clayes-sous-bois à saint cyr l'école
et à coignières reléguant le parti
socialiste comme troisième formation
dans ces communes dans les yvelines
globalement l'ump reste majoritaire avec
24 86% des voix s'est toutefois dix
points de moins qu'aux dernières
élections européennes de 2009
le front national le second partie du
département avec 17 77% des suffrages en
2009 à la liste d'hubert dubois n'avait
seulement totalisé 3 95%
c'est donc le grand gagnant de ces
élections du délit modem et troisième et
le parti socialiste 4e avec 11 89% des
voix
une consolation pour la formation de
gauche en 2009 dans les yvelines
harlem désir n'avait seulement réalisé
que 11 60% des voix
un perdant dans le département europe
ecologie les verts
en 2009 la liste menée par daniel cohn
bendit avait totalisé 19 58 % des voix
cinq ans plus tard la liste verte n'en
porte que 7,64 % des suffrages